¿Cuál es el peor insecto del planeta?
Quizás votes por el tábano,
o tal vez por la avispa,
pero para muchos
el peor de todos es el mosquito.
El zumbido,
la picadura,
la picazón,
el mosquito es una de las plagas
más odiadas del mundo.
En Alaska, los enjambres
de mosquitos puede ser tan densos
que de hecho pueden
asfixiar a un caribú.
Y las enfermedades transmitidas
por los mosquitos matan
a millones de habitantes
todos los años.
El azote que representan
los mosquitos no es nuevo.
Los mosquitos han existido
durante cientos de millones de años
y con el tiempo han evolucionado
junto con toda clase de especies,
incluyendo la nuestra.
De hecho hay miles de especies
de mosquitos en el mundo
pero todos comparten
la misma característica insidiosa:
chupan sangre;
son muy, muy buenos
chupando sangre.
Así lo hacen.
Después de aterrizar,
el mosquito unta
un poco de saliva sobre
la piel de la víctima,
la cual sirve de antiséptico,
entumeciendo el área de modo
que no notemos su picadura.
De hecho, esto es lo que causa
la hinchazón y la comezón.
Luego el mosquito usa
sus mandíbulas dentadas
para abrir un pequeño
hueco en la piel
permitiéndole explorar
con su probóscide
en busca de una vena sanguínea.
Cuando la encuentra
el suertudo parásito puede chupar
de 2 a 3 veces su peso en sangre.
Y no nos gusta mucho eso.
De hecho, los humanos
odiamos tanto a los mosquitos
que hemos gastado miles de millones
de dólares en el mundo
para mantenerlos alejados de nosotros
--velas de citronela,
repelentes de insectos,
hasta pesticidas agrícolas fortísimos--.
Pero los mosquitos
no solo son fastidiosos,
sino que también son mortales.
Los mosquitos pueden
transmitir de todo:
malaria,
fiebre amarilla,
el virus del Nilo Occidental,
hasta dengue.
Más de un millón de personas
en todo el mundo
mueren todos los años por enfermedades
transmitidas por los mosquitos,
y eso contando las personas.
Los caballos, perros y gatos
también pueden enfermarse
a causa de los mosquitos.
Entonces, si estos mosquitos
son tan ruines,
¿por qué no nos deshacemos de ellos?
Después de todo somos humanos,
y somos muy buenos
para extinguir especies.
Bueno, no es tan sencillo.
Deshacernos del mosquito
destruiría la fuente alimenticia
de muchísimos organismos
como las ranas,
los peces y los pájaros.
Sin ellos, las plantas perderían
sus polinizadores.
Pero algunos científicos dicen
que los mosquitos realmente
no son tan importantes.
Si nos libramos
de ellos, dicen,
otra especie simplemente
ocuparía su lugar
y probablemente tendríamos menos
muertes a causa de la malaria.
El problema es
que nadie sabe qué pasaría
si acabáramos con
todos los mosquitos.
Algo mejor podría
ocupar su lugar,
o quizás algo peor.
La pregunta es:
¿estamos dispuestos
a correr ese riesgo?